[Music]
are you ready for the best news about
your favorite movies and series well
great because we've got info on Super
Mario Brothers 2 the new Star Wars
movies and series and the exact release
date of Five Nights at Freddy's you can
also expect New Impressions of the Joker
sequel casting news on Deadpool 3 and
blade as well as lots of new series on
Harry Potter Game of Thrones and Batman
just last week we got a first look at
the upcoming Five Nights at Freddy's
movie the atmospheric image showed the
iconic Pizzeria where a large part of
the events will take place as well as
Freddy Fazbear himself standing next to
a child now there is new info about the
release of the horror movie those
responsible surprisingly announced that
they are planning a double release for
the game adaptation in concrete terms
this means that Five Nights at Freddy's
will be screened as usual in theaters on
October 27 2023 but will also be
available on the US streaming service
peacock at the same time the same
approach has already been chosen for the
horrorflix Halloween kills and Halloween
ends which are also distributed by
Universal Pictures such a practice of
day and date releases caused a notable
stir in 2021 when Warner Brothers
decided to release all of the year's
movies in both streaming and theaters at
once due to the pandemic at the time
there was a lot of criticism especially
from Cinema operators but considering
the potentially empty movie theaters one
could understand the choice in a way
with Five Nights at Freddy's of course
that's not the reason instead the
Strategic goal will be to further push
the peacock streaming service and gain
subscribers originally a film adaptation
of the popular horror games around the
creepy animatronic characters was held
out in Prospect by Warner Brothers back
in 2015 but the project was eventually
passed on to bloom house and Universal
Pictures who wrapped up filming on April
3rd the official release date is now
October 27 2023. what would you like to
see in the Freddy movie are you going to
watch it directly on the streaming
service or do you want to enjoy the
thrill in the movie theater let us know
your plans in the comments down below
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman are
certainly the focus of attention in
Deadpool 3. nevertheless we are looking
forward to the return of two more
beloved characters which have now been
announced we're talking about Morena
Baccarin and Stefan capisic Baccarin
already played the fiancee of the
titular character Wade Wilson as Vanessa
in Deadpool and Deadpool 2. in addition
to the Marvel films she has also
appeared in the DC series Gotham and was
heard on the flash as the voice of the
computer Gideon Stefan capisic meanwhile
embodies the X-Men character Colossus in
the Deadpool Universe we are
particularly interested to see how he
interacts with his X-Men colleague
Wolverine after all Logan's serious
nature is somewhat different from that
of the peaceful Giant in addition to
Baccarin and capisic we will also see
Karen Sony as the cab driver depender
and Leslie Uggams as blind Al again in
Deadpool 3. the cast of Marvel's blade
has also been expanded by a familiar
name according to a report by deadline
leading man mahershala Ali is now joined
by actress Mia goth genre lovers know
her mainly from horror flicks like
Superior X and pearl where her
performance has always been a highlight
for many however details about her role
are not yet known while blade is
currently slated for a theatrical
release on September 6 2024 Deadpool 3
is scheduled to be released on November
8th 2024.
the Star Wars celebration recently took
place in the British Capital London as
anticipated some news about upcoming
Star Wars movies and series were
announced at the annual event which is
considered the biggest gathering around
the popular franchise a new film that is
to be set almost 15 years after the
events of the rise of Skywalker
attracted the most attention as
lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy
confirmed Rey will play the lead role in
this one however with respect to the
moderately popular sequel Trilogy with
the character this is rather
controversial among fans the main focus
will be on the rebuilding of the Jedi
order in which Rey will play an
essential part it is already known that
actress Daisy Ridley will once again
take on her role Miss Marvel director
charmeen obey chenoy is to be the
director of the film in addition Kennedy
announced plans to make one film each
with Logan and Indiana Jones 5 director
James Mangold and Star Wars the Clone
Wars director Dave filoni the first is
to revolve around the very first Jedi
while Tony will focus on the new
Republic besides the three movies there
is also news about Star Wars series one
highlight for example is the first
teaser for Ahsoka with Rosario Dawson
which was published online immediately
after its Premiere the next series is
Star Wars the acolyte showrunner Leslie
Headland revealed that her series will
be a cross between the Disney spectacle
Frozen and the Bloody Tarantino film
Kill Bill she also added that people
should be braced for things they haven't
seen before in any Live Action Project
the series is set for release next year
there is considerably less information
about Star Wars Skeleton Crew although
there were first shots from the series
there are hardly any other further
announcements at least the shooting of
skeleton crew was set to be completed
and we can look forward to a Premiere
later this year not only new but also
already existing series partly received
new updates for example a second season
of The Anthology series Star Wars
Visions with a total of Nine episodes
will be released in early May Star Wars
Tale of the Jedi and Star Wars the bad
batch will also receive another season
so in summary there was a lot of news
from this year's Star Wars celebration
though it wasn't all that detailed what
news were you most excited about and
what are your thoughts on the new movie
starring Rey we are curious to hear your
opinions
while the Super Mario Brothers movie is
breaking all kinds of records and the
ending raises interesting questions many
people want to know one thing above all
what are the prospects for a Super Mario
Brothers movie 2. Chris melodandre the
studio chief of Illumination was asked
by Bloomberg about plans regarding a
sequel the answer speaks for itself he
is currently not allowed to talk about
it for us that translates to of course
sequels are to be expected considering
the Studio's previous approach of
continuing hits like Despicable Me or
the minions this is hardly surprising
given the huge success of the Super
Mario Brothers movie one of the movie's
highlights is Shirley Bowser played by
Jack Black also talked to Gamespot about
the future of the franchise he doesn't
see it as a given that Bowser will
return as the bad guy for a second part
instead though he could team up with
Mario and the others against an even
bigger villain Wario and who should
embody him well none other than the last
of a star Pedro Pascal we could easily
imagine worse things for Super Mario
Brothers 2.
parent company Warner Brothers merges
HBO Max and Discovery plus into a single
offering many new series have now been
announced at a big press event for the
new Max streaming service fans of the
two iconic Gremlin movies can look
forward to an animated series called
Gremlins secrets of the Mogwai for which
a first teaser trailer has also been
published the US release date is May 23
2023 following the recent announcement
that a new Game of Thrones series about
aegon the Conqueror is in the works
another project is about to follow a
night of the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge
Knight will be a series about the
legendary Knight dunk and his Squire egg
whose Adventures have already been
recorded many times in the books a
release date has not yet been revealed
Batman fans also enjoyed the first
teaser for the series The Penguin with
Colin Farrell which promises the same
dark atmosphere as the Batman with
Robert Pattinson the series is set for
release in 2024 probably the biggest
sensation was caused by the official
first teaser for the new Harry Potter
series this means that it is finally
confirmed that the seven season remake
of the books is on its way we are still
waiting with great excitement for the
casting process the recasting of the
iconic roles of Daniel Radcliffe Emma
Watson and Rupert Grint will certainly
be a difficult task
just recently snapshots of the filming
of Joker Folia do were leaked granting a
glimpse behind the scenes they included
leading actress Lady Gaga who was seen
for the first time with her complete
outfit as well as hints of an appearance
by Harvey Dent Alias Two-Face now more
pictures of the Joker sequel came out
she chewing on the sequel to the most
successful R-rated film of all time was
officially wrapped up last week director
Todd Phillips shared two new images that
complete this month-long shoot featured
are the lead actors Lady Gaga and
Joaquin Phoenix while Gaga is shown as
Harley Quinn with smudged makeup and
peroxide blonde hair we get to see
Phoenix in a shot from below where he
wears one of his signature suits in the
caption Phillips expresses his gratitude
to the two actors and the entire cast
and crew who according to the director
are among the best the film industry
currently has to offer Phillips will now
crawl into a cave and put everything
together meaning of course that the
post-production phase is now underway in
addition to the main actors other Top
Class ones such as Harry Potter star
Brendan Gleeson and get out actress
Catherine Keener have joined the cast we
can also look forward to the return of
zazi Beats as Arthur's neighbor Sophie
as far as plot is concerned Joker Foley
Adu is about continuing the story of the
first part after being seen in the
psychiatric ward at the end Arthur will
get support from Harley Quinn as in the
comics she will presumably first work as
a psychiatrist and later fall in love
with her patient Arthur and catches
Insanity the movie will also contain
some musical packages which will make
the sequel very different from its
Forerunner until the scheduled
theatrical release those in charge still
have more than a year to give it the
Final Touch Joker 2 Folia do is slated
for release on October 4th 2024.
this week we were swamped with
announcements which movie and series are
you looking forward to the most share
with us in the comments what you're most
excited about and why we can't wait to
hear which releases you're looking
forward to the most and we'll be sure to
keep an eye out for them in the future
and if you want check out our Mad Max
furiosa movie preview as well as our
video about John Wick 4 where we go into
more detail about the Epic ending and
the post-credits scene thanks for
watching
thank you
[Music]
foreign